♪ ♪
- Hi, I'm Chuck Cook
in Dundee, Oregon.
And welcome to my little shop.
I have my pile of brick
forge, here.
I bought two burners,
but everything else
was recycled firebrick..
It's on a rolling cart,
but the rolling cart's
actually dying.
It's propped up, so it
can't move at the moment.
Drill press, welding station,
I have a really old MIG--
a stick welder
which is the welder I use most
down there.
I am not a great welder.
You know, welding was one of
the problems I had
during the challenges,
simply because I'd never
used a MIG
quite that advanced.
Mine's pretty old school.
♪ ♪
- So, yeah,
this is my forge area
and this whole area
used to just be
my whole shop.
But over time as I started
getting new tools,
I moved all my other machines
and stuff to a different area.
Still have my original forge
that I first started with.
I don't use this anvil anymore,
but this was my first one,
and it was made
out of railroad track.
It wasn't the best at all,
but this is really where
my passion for bladesmithing
came from,
was when I first
worked on this one.
I'm really more of
an organized person,
so I like to have everything,
you know,
up on the wall
if I'm not using it.
This is my power hammer.
And I absolutely
love this thing
because I can work on
several pieces of metal at once
since you're not tiring
yourself out forging by hand.
- My electric heat treat oven.
I did electric with this
because it's digitally
controlled,
so I can set the temperature.
The challenges really comes
into being able
to fit as much equipment in
in such a small space.
I have dreams of having
a power hammer like Big BLU,
but at the moment, I don't know
where I'd even fit
that thing in here
if I get one.
- So this is the other
portion of my shop.
Kinda took over this area.
Being that I make
kitchen knives,
this is all my different
handle materials
I usually use for those.
They're a much higher price.
Usually a little more brittle,
though, so--
This is mostly more of,
like, the design table
and where I keep all of
my knives that are
currently in production,
so you see these
were just freshly forged.
And I had to
stop working on them
because I had to start
training for this competition.
That's my shop.
It's not as big as the studio,
but I'm comfortable here
and I know my tools well.
And I've got
a lot of work to do,
but we're gonna get it done.